[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa france24 ya está lista más
romeros a la con nosotros en el estudio
mar bienvenida feliz inicio de semana y
después de más de dos años de pandemia
todavía hay gente que nunca se ha
contagiado de kobe 19 parece imposible
pero es cierto mar porque porque
nosotros además dos veces esto te iba a
decir todavía hay respuestas inciertas
sobre por qué hay gente que no se
contagia del coach pero lo que está
claro es que ni tú ni yo somos ese grupo
de personas hay hay varios estudios y
varios grupos de investigación que están
buscando estos perfiles de personas que
no se han contagiado nunca de kobe y
sobre todo también para ver qué
respuestas pueden esconder alrededor de
nuevos tratamientos o nuevas
posibilidades para evitar la enfermedad
estamos con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia para
entender mucho mejor de qué se trata
este fenómeno para empezar como pueden
estar seguros en estos estudios de que
las personas efectivamente no se han
contagiado nunca de kobe y no es que
hayan tenido por ejemplo un caso a
sintomático
o la mar lo que pasa es que a los
trabajadores de la salud nos han hecho
pruebas durante mucho tiempo y
secuencialmente recordemos que las
personas que trabajamos con pacientes
tenemos que hacer periódicamente la
prueba pues para hacer aislamientos
preventivos se han encontrado en un
grupo de estos trabajos de la salud que
no hicieron cero conversión es decir que
no han hecho anticuerpos no se conoce si
es una infección subclínica o realmente
es que curaron el virus o no respondan
ya la ahí es donde radican los estudios
y antes están buscando alguna respuesta
hola doctor muy buen día los saludos de
nuevo y le quiero preguntar entonces si
la genética podría ser un factor a la
respuesta para entender por qué hay
gente totalmente inmune a este virus
si lo que se está buscando es eso cuáles
son los marcadores genéticos que
predisponen a que sea una enfermedad que
sea sub clínica o lo contrario también
hemos encontrado y esto ya lo tenemos
documentado incluso en la región donde
tenemos un estudio en donde encontramos
pacientes que tienen a sus espira
genética para tener un desenlace peor es
decir que si hay unos condicionantes
genéticos que permiten o de curar la
enfermedad o agravar la enfermedad y eso
va a ser la respuesta pues para futuras
vacunas y tratamientos
doctor hay algunos otros estudios
también hechos en trabajadores de la
salud como decía que apuntan que la
clave también estaba en esas células de
esas células del sistema inmune que
tienen memoria que papel influyeron en
evitar que se contagiarán del cob y
durante tanto tiempo
recordemos que la inmunidad son dos
tipos de células clase las que producen
los anticuerpos y las células que
generan una respuesta celular mucho más
prolongada y que puede generar memoria
que las células ve también estas células
lo que hacen es perpetuar la inmunidad
es decir que dure mucho más tiempo eso
hace que cuando nosotros vacunamos de
polio cuando niños durante toda la vida
tengamos este tipo de inmunidad esta
seria este todavía no hay métodos
comerciales para saber cuál es o quiénes
las fabrican o qué cantidad tenemos pero
va a ser la respuesta para saber cuándo
vacunarnos cuando re vacunarnos quien
persona enferma más y qué persona
enferma menos doctor también le quiero
preguntar qué tratamientos nuevos se
podrían desarrollar al estudiar esta
inmunidad
el entender la respuesta inmunológica va
a diseñar por ejemplo tipos de cuerpos
que me parecen mucho más efectivos o
también se puede identificar qué
personas son más susceptibles y se van a
priorizar para inmunización o también
qué tipo de inmunidad se va a medir
cuando hagamos la vacunación para saber
la revacunación realmente entender esta
dinámica permitiría todo un aumento
terapéutico que necesitamos tanto porque
recordemos que la pandemia no se ha ido
y cuando llegamos a fase endémica no
quiere decir que sean menos drive
simplemente que menos personas se
afectan pero la gravedad sigue igual y
las personas pueden fallecer por esta
enfermedad por eso debemos estudiarla
perfectamente para poder diseñar
tratamientos futuros y para terminar en
la misma línea podemos llegar a imaginar
una vacuna por ejemplo que no sólo
prevenga contra la enfermedad del cómic
19 sino que incluso prevenga contra la
infección no y que no podamos
infectarnos del cobi 19 del virus que lo
provoca gracias a estudiar estos tipos
de inmunidad es de estas personas
claro que sí ahora viene una segunda
generación de vacunas esta primera
generación es una respuesta a la
emergencia se están diseñando algunas
que producen esta inmunidad celular y
también se están combinando hay estudios
de vacunas que vienen con virus
sincitial respiratorio influencia hoy en
una sola vacuna y ya se están haciendo
pruebas clínicas y seguramente esta
próxima década va a ser la era de la
vacunología donde varios tipos de
vacunas y entendiendo la respuesta
inmune se van a diseñar para prevenir
esta y otras infecciones respiratorias
que nos aquejan de acuerdo a los cambios
climáticos y ojalá que no sean en otra
pandemia también recordamos que cuando
salieron en las nuevas variantes del
cobi 19 lo largo de todo este de estos
dos años de pandemia se anunciaron que
van a haber vacunas específicas contra
por ejemplo la variante omicron o la
variante delta que sabemos del
desarrollo de estas vacunas y no sería
mejor aprovechar a hacer una vacuna más
genérica en vez de vacunas específicas
por las variantes
si se está trabajando más en una vacuna
universal que no una por variante pero
viene una generación de vacunas de
variantes que llena sociedad la que ya
conocemos y hay vacunas que se están
haciendo universal donde ya no es para
las variantes sino para el sars cop
identificando material genético que es
uniforme en todas las variantes y
generar una inmunidad más a largo plazo
de eso se trata de prevenir la
enfermedad a largo plazo y no cada
variante porque sería imposible tocaría
diseñar vacunas cada dos meses
claro pues doctor gracias a como siempre
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france a 24
analizando temas de salud de actualidad
gracias a también marx por acompañarnos
como siempre y recordemos que estábamos
hablando con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia asesor
científico de france